era tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video sono parigi e dolci siamo su
just 2014 rega non vedevo l'ora che
uscisse anche se a ballare
effettivamente sempre un bradipo il
calore ma vi giuro che mi diverto un
casino 15 o ragazzi che lo aspettavo
come un bambino a natale e non vedo
veramente l'ora di averlo ragazzi ci
sono un miliardo di canzoni comunque ho
letto che si può staccare il microfono
allawi e cantare sotto le fasi delle
canzoni questo avverte ragazzi questa
cosa non la dovevano mettere perché sarà
la nostra rovina con che dire iniziare
con starci questa sia centralmente tanta
roba da baggio a cliccare già faccio
ragazzi
[Musica]
ci siamo reagan non so quanto possa
essere diverso da just dance precedente
comunque prima canzone star sesso ci
prova ma che non so come può uscire
la partenza è sexy e questo mi piace
si sapeva mettere una gonna calcio
[Musica]
bellissimo ragazzo questo ho sempre
sognato di farlo troppo bello ragazza
metto il microfono dal senso si spegna
per la tristezza
io lo farò vi giuro dal prossimo
episodio non lo prendo lo metto ragazzi
visto cadendo vantaggio spesso troppo di
un prezzo non ci posso credere sia
ragazzi ho preso frivola ma cosa
incredibile
ciò significa che andranno tutti bene
quest'anno e non prezzato
[Musica]
la stessa
c'è da fare in affari j
non so come cazzo si fanno stiparli
basta vi supplico cos'è non facciamo
movimenti così sexy da troppo tempo
ragazzi e ballo più più bello del mondo
mi piace troppo ok ragazzi nessuno
esageratamente strofe cioè non posso
scegliere cazzo assurdo
andiamo con cash è così bikeasia che non
mi ha in mente l'uso finora vediamo di
riuscire a fare la danza col panda io
voglio fare il panna però cazzo mi
divertirei troppo impersoniamo un panda
non so che cazzo porsi fuori ma di
sicuro avrà molta più coordinazione di
me questo è sicuro tu che da spazio
ragazzi
il pazzo è quanto sono film mamma mia
che questo questa è veramente sexy
questo mi si addice
ma non lavate che siamo praticamente
identici è uguale praga ho sempre
sognato di figli per suonare il cazzo si
parla mentre palmo e fantastico
[Musica]
maria
[Applauso]
lei che fa
[Musica]
ma
perché no
è così che facciamo difendere chi siamo
cazzo ci sono con indietro evitando
questo qualcuno dietro soffietti
[Musica]
il suo ragazzo mira poi così ragazza e
nicki minaj in un video e notizie
ma lo faccio per poi chissenefrega
ragazzi basta palermo stupido banda di
cazzo non sono esageratamente
sfruttabile
[Musica]
a parte il 5
nole
ragazzi della mia età ha perso ecco di
fatto
[Musica]
cioè in cash ha spiegato dalla ragazza
così gnocca sulle spalle vabbè pazienza
ho sempre sognato di portare testa sulle
spalle
vicino però
[Musica]
a regà da adesso in avanti dovete far
vedere questo video è già perché
dobbiamo guardare insieme e devo
prenderla sue spalle
[Musica]
[Applauso]
l'aia è stato un [ __ ] suicidio
[Musica]
questo non me la faccio in questo
episodio aspettate il prossimo lei ha
fatto di fare l'ultima perché sono
disastrato facciamo facciamo passato mi
piace mi piace il ritmo sento e quando
sotto ritmo non è mai una bella cosa
intervenire alta ma vabbè chi sei forte
[Musica]
mi è piaciuta la partenza però mi fa
sentire un bacio caso mi sento fonzie di
happy day che questo era peggio di
maastricht
questo testo merito mi piace questo è un
palo di michael jackson to date non
fosse visto componendo io resisto vai
che c'è una camera di un metro per un
metro
quanto può essere ballato in una pista
la fanno cosa succede che c'è tutto so
fazio sono ragazzi e ragazze sexy stanno
ballando al mio fianco mi sembra giusto
male
[Musica]
lo zio
la bambina
beh
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ma devo dare una prima o poi mi sento mi
sento a mio agio
appare così credetemi
[Musica]
a destra
ebbene con ibra
c'è una mega cazzo almeno uno almeno la
soddisfazione questo pazzo una [ __ ]
stella ragazzi sono non lo faccio
sono attirato tantissimo ma non lo
faccio lo farò nel prossimo episodio
sono troppo distrutto credetemi
ragazzi vi ringrazio per i 200 mila
iscritti
scusate mi sono fatto inizio video e
ricordatevi che domani che sabato uscirà
il video speciale quindi non perdetevelo
io chiudo più l'episodio vado a ficcarmi
direttamente nel frigorifero se
permettete che se mi è piaciuto come al
solito risulti momento mi piace anche la
paglia di facebook che come ogni video
trovate la descrizione 60 iscritti vi
iscrivete non ci vediamo il prossimo
vito beh ragazzi